hi i'm max kaiser this is the kaiser
report we're back from summer solutions
no more solutions no no no only problems
now for the next
10 months yeah well
let's talk about the biggest thing that
happened while we were away
on vacation and that is warren buffett
has obviously used that opportunity
while we were away
to make a major major major
change in his portfolio and which
indicates that kaiser report
has been right for the past 10 years he
dumped
many of his banking shares and went long
gold miner barrick the biggest gold
miner in the world
so max what do you think about this sea
change in his portfolio
right well it was obvious that he would
have to get into gold gold mining gold
bullion
at some point he had too much cash he
was
underperforming the stock market for 15
years
um he had made an enormous mistake in
airlines again for the second time in
his career
took a huge loss and
um he never understood technology got in
very late and
he's got a problem now with all the
money that he helped
bring into existence by having the
government bail him out
perpetually uh not not
2008 was a huge bailout of warren
buffett and they had to print
trillions of dollars uh he used to base
the value of the fiat money the us
dollar and the only protection now he
has as a way to preserve wealth
is to get into gold so this is the first
foray into gold
i anticipate that within two years
20 to 30 percent of the berkshire
portfolio will be gold or
exposed to gold buffett's celebrating 90
years
you know 90-year birthday you know he's
not a spring chicken anymore i think
charlie munger is a few years older
so they've gotten out think about
preservation of capital they made tons
of mistakes now they just have to
salvage what they can
of course one thing you can point to
this
and say is that this is part of perhaps
his dispute with the fed because
remember
he did want to bail out the airlines
i in a way that would give him a good
deal and a bigger percentage of the big
four airlines in america
but who outbid him that was the u.s
federal reserve
they gave no strings attached to their
free money to the airlines
which is basically never going to have
to be paid back so of course warren
buffett then dumped his airline shares
and then dumped his banking shares in
the second quarter
and uh while he was buying gold and
buying barrack at half a billion dollars
worth of barrick gold
he um i want to point out that colombia
the country
you know they sold two-thirds of their
gold
in june alone so
you know they were getting out there's
always dumb money and there's always
smart money at the table so if you don't
know who the sucker is at the table
it it could be you that's you right well
you know the fed is out buffering
buffett right he
fed warren taught fraud how to commit
fraud to the central bank
you print a lot of money and then buy
stocks that go up because you're buying
stocks that go up
right so he made that game possible and
so but the fed figured out wait a minute
why are we letting warren take all this
fraud money
we should get some of this fraud money
so now the fed is out
buffering buffett so there's nothing
left for buffett to do you know he is
entering
the game of precious metals and precious
metals
is a non-stop sort of manipulated market
jp morgan has been fined over the past
few years
for manipulating the the prices on gold
and silver
i i think they're still under criminal
indictment actually they're there
there's a criminal investigation from
the department of justice
but the biggest oldest bullion bank in
the world is scotia bank
and they've just been fined 127 million
dollars
for manipulating gold prices through
spoofing
this is on top of 800 million that they
were already fine like one or two years
ago
and then they failed to disclose some
information in that settlement so
the cftc and the department of justice
are finding them some more
127 million but again this is something
that kaiser report has had right
where the major you know mainstream
media has wrong where they say
it's it's a total conspiracy theory to
think
that prices can be manipulated because
for every buyer
there's a seller right now that's uh
clear i hope by now that these gold
prices and
markets all over the world are
manipulated using in this case they
highlight
spoofing you know putting in fake orders
to nudge the price up and down and
but there's 20 different ways you can
manipulate prices and we've talked about
them before
look the world is on a gold standard
it's been on a gold standard for
a thousand years central banks are on a
gold standard when they settle trades
it's with gold they don't use paper
this idea that we have a fiat money
standard is of complete hoax
in order for that to be perpetuated
they've had to
suppress the price of gold manipulating
the price of gold
so many banks have been fined for this
now it's such a documented historical
fact that they've manipulated the price
of gold but like the
gold pool the 1960s you can only do it
for so long and then
the market ultimately wins out and now
the market's saying you know what
without the manipulation the price of
gold would be three thousand dollars
right now and now we have to go to 3 000
and spank you we have to spank you hard
really hard and uh buffett sees the
trend and goes i don't want to be
spanked
i got to get into gold and of course
you know that part of the resistance to
saying that this
exists is because a lot of people don't
want to say well you know
why would the u.s treasury or u.s
government care the value about the
value of the dollar
obviously they do they care about the
value of all uh
fiat currencies but nevertheless you
know
what they've been doing is this
manipulation by the way
it's been going on since from 2008 to
2016.
this is what scotiabank was fined for
even though kaiser report has been
covering this non-stop
so they were never afraid of being
exposed even though we were talking
about spoofing
and you know what spoofing does is they
pretend they put in an order from
massive buy or a massive cell mostly
usually a massive cell to
to panic other investors in the market
they think oh my god everybody's about
to dump their gold
and so they dump their gold fast and and
get a lower price than they
what they would have i mean this is a
smash and grab but in a very
sophisticated form because
you know if any ordinary joe baggett
donuts did this they would be doing you
know 10 20 30 years in prison
but here they get a fine who knows how
much their gains were by the way
and we'll never know because they
settled with with the authorities
right let me let me in a little secret
right there is no such thing as
fiat money and there is no inflation
and there is no deflation and the only
thing there is
to think about are interest rates and
interest rate apartheid the value of the
fiat money is important in relation to
gold in that you can keep interest rates
near zero so that if you are a white guy
like jamie dimon on wall street your
cost of borrowing is zero
if you're a black guy living in the
ghetto your cost of borrowing is 2 000
it's called interest rate apartheid and
it's practiced right here in america and
all over the world
the ghetto of high interest rates if you
don't borrowing money to zero percent
interest rate
you live it in the ghetto and that's the
fact okay so
if you can't deal with it then you're
going to have to
maybe go to a psychiatrist and adjust
your thinking so you can perceive the
truth in its fullest
straight on speaking of perception and
market participants is
something interesting has been happening
over the summer and that is tesla
has been rocketing continuing to rock it
it's up five and a half percent
since march but the interesting thing is
it really went off on a tear
when it's once it did a stock split
which you know
just like the people who piled in on the
bankrupt companies
like hertz and whiting petroleum uh even
though they were gonna lose everything
here
is like splitting your stock doesn't add
any value to the company but it makes
people feel wealthier because they have
instead of having a hundred
then they have 400 shares right well
there's a couple of stories here first
of all tesla
is a meme that's worth close to 400
billion dollars in the meme economy and
i've been saying that for years now you
know
it's not an auto company it's not a
technological company it's a meme
that is embraced by the robin traders
and other meme traders around the world
and as a 400 billion dollar meme that's
what it's worth that's how you value it
second of all it's funny people are
saying oh tesla's up on the stock split
news
and they don't mention at all that apple
computers up on
stock split news apple computer splits
its stock four for one and it's up
by 30 or 40 billion dollars much more in
dollar terms than tesla was purely on a
stock split news
this is an old wall street saw stocks go
up on stock splits
that's been going on for 100 years uh
why tesla is being pointed out versus
apple i don't know
but tesla is more importantly a name it
exists
as a name um that's pretty much its
value
so i also here did mention tesla rather
than apple
because tesla you know grabbed the
headlines and
it's it does drive people crazy because
you know apple sells a lot of products
and tesla doesn't necessarily
sell so many products so the fact that
they just keep going up
despite being like a such a target
online look at my twitter stream i don't
see a single mention of
apple up on split i see thousands of
mentions of tesla up on split so just
looking at my twitter as
a as an analysis of what the perception
is out there for some reason people
don't see that
there's something else going on with
that so
there was also big news while we were
away in the bitcoin space and that was
uh this guy dave
portnoy from bar still sports bought
some bitcoin
after the winklevi went out there to uh
talk him into it and dumped it two or
three days later
and uh that was the end of the story he
did say
interestingly he did tweet that he is
perhaps going to enter back into the
bitcoin space
with half a million dollars because
simply because
he likes the memes right he's the
typical
uh trader of altcoins as they're called
and
he got sucked in at uh into a garbage
coin
and uh on the pretense of being
interested in bitcoin
and he was suckered into that coin
through the winklevi who
have an exchange they trade a lot of
junk as does coinbase
these are unregulated casinos in america
they should be regulated as casinos to
re comply with the law but they're not
for some reason
and just like if you can go into a
casino you get a free drink
and then they take all your money dave
portney he went into the casino saying
oh this is bitcoin
and within less than three days he was
losing money
on the casino of terrible altcoins you
know
now because he's being uh the poster
child of getting wrecked
he's like oh maybe i need to redeem
myself as a meme
and i'm going to go back in he'll get
wrecked again so
this wrecking the wrecking cycle is
about to chew up this
guy pretty badly i might add that
something like 97 percent of all
investors in bitcoin have made money
without at whatever price you bought um
so they've
so he's done a good job of losing money
and finally like while we were away we
also started a new podcast called orange
pill podcast
it's a long deep dive into all sorts of
stories that are really important
to it's like a mix of summer solutions
and kaiser report
and our old podcast truth about markets
and like it's a whole assembly it's a
chimera
it's a chimera of of of fun and
shenanigans shenanigans orange pills
it's all there
it's orange pills is the next thing you
take after the red pill
and you know if if we're entering a new
renaissance as we had said in the first
of our summer solutions
that this is the place to go to
understand how
what the rebirth will look like and what
options we have uh coming forward
unfortunately we don't have it in
spanish
dubbed in spanish because we know we
have a huge audience out there
for kaiser report in the spanish
language it is the biggest best audience
in the world i have to say this is the
number one reason
we do kaiser report is for the
spanish-speaking audience
hey we gotta take a break when we come
back much more coming your way
[Music]
welcome back to the kaiser report i'm
max keiser time now to go to craig hemke
over there tfmetalsreport.com welcome
back craig
hi max you know uh as this episode airs
of kaiser report
virtual jackson hole has just ended
now we're going to talk about jerome
powell do you expect
he'll have actually said anything
consequential in any way or
ultimately just be about the idea of
central bankers have
again and again money printer go burr
and what do you think about these guys
over there at jackson hole and virtual
jackson hall starting up a new
punk band called virtual jackson hole in
the wannabes
yeah it's pretty i mean they've missed
out on their big trip this year they go
out there every year you know and they
have a little hoedown and
have their fun they can't do that this
year i i don't know will it be
consequential i guess that depends on
how we define consequential but i
i think the tea leaves have been out
there to be read the trial balloons have
been floated
at least for the last month gold and
silver really took off on july 17th if
anybody wants to pull up a chart and
look at that and also on july 17th
in the wee hours of the morning an
article magically appeared on bloomberg
stating that a major policy change was
going to be coming from the fed and soon
and that policy change was going to be
twofold one it was going to be a
reassessment of how hot they can let
inflation go before they start hiking
rates
and because they can't let rates go up
there on the long term they're also
going to combine some form of yield
curve control with it
that institutionalizes really
sharply negative real interest rates and
i know you and i have talked about this
in the past how bullish that is for the
precious metals when that happens
and that's why we rallied so sharply
late in july and early august
so we'll see um other reports have
indicated that this speech is coming
and that's what he's going to be talking
about and then we've got the next fomc
meeting in
uh i guess three weeks from now two and
a half weeks from now
so i think all this stuff is pending for
september we'll just see if he
kick-starts it
let's focus on something here so you
imagine the it institutionalizes
negative interest rates okay so let's
unpack that a little bit because for
people listening that
they might be confused because the
stated objection is to raise rates
or to raise inflation to two percent or
higher right that's the stated objection
and in so doing they're going to create
more
negative interest rates right so explain
how that works well negative real or
inflation-adjusted interest rates that's
the key
the key metric here you know the whole
nominal rates i mean the 10-year
treasury note has yielded under one
percent now since
april and it almost looks like someone
or somebody has already put in yield
curve control because anytime it falls
below about 60 basis points it
automatically goes back up and if it
gets above 75 it goes back down
just go through the mathematics here in
other words if in fact
rates or if in fact inflation is stated
at two percent
the way to get to real rates is you take
that number and you subtract it from the
nominal rate
right and you turn it in turn that bond
into a guaranteed loser from a
purchasing power
might think standpoint but let me just
walk through this for a second so they
say they want to
increase inflation and they have a
target
of of inflation that's higher than where
it is now
that will guarantee absolutely guarantee
that they're going to go down the rabbit
hole of more negative rates
which is in fact deflation so they
are stating a categorical
lie that they're trying to create
inflation
by increasing the rates of inflation
that will cause real rates to be
absolutely
negative so by yield curve management
right that's an attempt to say well we
know actually what we're saying is false
that we're going to create inflation by
raising rates because it actually
creates
in negative interest rates so we're
going to therefore
expand the remit of the fed from the
short-term
discount window the discount rate we're
now going to say we control everything
we control the 10-year the 20-year the
30-year
we control it all right and you out
there
in the world no matter what you see
it's false because now we own it all at
the fed
and we control the horizontal and the
vertical
we control everything right so they in
other words they're signaling
a dictatorship right yeah thank you good
night
that's it yeah more or less
uh we couldn't be in a more centrally
planned global economy than
we'd have at that point i mean there are
no market forces left
and i i think you've nailed it and i
don't see any other way out
max i mean they don't want to call it
modern monetary theory at this point
but in all sense that's what it is i
mean we are
printing dollars in every single nation
and every single nations
are not dollars but currency and every
single nation
central bank is monetizing it and here
in the us
um it's they're monetizing basically
every single new
issuance of debt and so is it modern
monetary theory and maybe not name but i
mean i
we're there so the emperors of the past
whether it's caesar
or emperors under the roman empire or
emperors
of in the east right the byzantine
uh they always eventually started to
clip coins right they debased the
currency
as a way to exert dictatorship over the
economy
by giving people less and less for their
work until such time as the empire
collapses
so america now is in without a doubt we
can state categorically they've entered
into a fatal stage of the empire
by clipping their coins so horribly by
giving the fed
a dictatorship power that we can expect
very quickly now a total collapse of the
american economy and its influence
around the world
thanks to the fed full stop craig your
thoughts well it was
mathematical certainty at some point um
i'm not sure if we're on the verge of
total collapses yet but we're headed
that direction
you know i you and i have joked in the
past max you don't go around predicting
the end of the world because you're only
going to be right once
so it may not be a total collapse in the
next couple of months but we're
certainly headed that direction
and every every single fiat currency
regime that's been tried in the past has
been as you suggest
completely wiped out over time because
you get you know
go by mars style you know eventually
you're just printing so much of it that
it all just trends to be worthless
we're headed that direction again you
know an interesting thing about this
inflation fight
max and it kind of ties back to the
stuff you and i have talked on off
about are off and on about for the last
10 years is this
uh overt now uh
manipulation that we saw of precious
metals prices really going all the way
back to 1975 when the futures contracts
first started trading
i mean you could clearly see it we now
have uh
these fines being paid and and rico
statutes being invoked and then
department of justice investigations all
this kind of stuff
and there was always an effort made to
kind of suppress the prices
so as to install instill confidence
excuse me in the dollar in the other
fiat currency
but i wonder if now we're seeing kind of
a regime change if you will in that
mindset because these central bankers
have bigger fish to fry and the biggest
fish is trying to spark this
inflation that we talked about so that
you can
manage the debt of yesterday and kind of
cheaper currency of tomorrow
and how if they're not successful in
doing it just by printing cash because
as you said i mean you kind of get this
loop
that keeps it from being successful
maybe one of their final tools in the
toolbox will be just to simply revalue
gold and silver higher you know yeah
yeah let me get to gold and silver craig
hempke this is uh first of all as you
point out
they keep talking about inflation it's
the same way jim jones suggested
everyone drink the kool-aid to seek
nirvana
right i mean he's a cult leader he's a
death cult the fed is a death cult let's
be let's be clear
one guy who's not fooled is warren
buffett who realizes that when the fed
outbid him for airline stocks the game
was up for berkshire hathaway
and their modus operandi of the past 40
years to
essentially game the system but when the
fed starts to gaming warren buffett
more than warren buffett can game the
system it's game over
so he dumped his bank stocks and he
started buying gold stocks something
that he said he would never do
ever in his career dinner complete about
face
and he's getting out of dodge right he
sees the system is about to blow up
and he's preparing for it craig i i
suppose and
obviously that old grease ball's i mean
he's no dummy he wants to make money
and what other sector besides the
precious metals mining sector
is now steadily increasing earnings and
increasing dividends you know in a post
covered world nobody
no other sector is the gold sector is
okay so we put some money there
i you know i don't know how much i want
to read into the fact that he bought
some barrack
other than for anybody wanting to trade
and make their own little fiat
you know they always say just follow
what warren does kind of like you know
don't fight the fed but look he's gonna
lead a lot of institutional money
uh to take another look if not make some
additional investments in the sector
and you and i have talked about this
before i mean as the global asset
allocation shifts
even just a little bit from maybe one
percent of all assets in gold and silver
in the shares to two percent oh my gosh
that's a lot of additional money chasing
a finite amount of companies and so
you know what his ultimate what you can
read into ultimately what
he may be doing or trying to say at the
same time yeah if you just want to play
along
i think that's a signal that there's a
lot of institutional i mean big time
institutional hedge fund pension fund
money that's probably going to be coming
into gold and silver in the months ahead
right but put this in the context here
he bought this gold stock barrick
and he dumped financials against a
background
where uh it's clear that um
he's going to be facing the headwinds of
a falling
fiat money falling dollar and he's
trying to position himself ahead of this
in a way that is wealth preservation at
this point
in terms of being in context of what of
what
he's doing overall um i think it speaks
volumes about his complete lack of
confidence in the american economy
yeah and i i mean again guys no dummy
and anybody we began this conversation
talking about negative real interest
rates negative inflation-adjusted
interest rates where the nominal rate is
one but the inflation rate is three
and so you're losing two percent a year
and that historically
those negative real rates have been the
key driver of gold prices i mean the the
link is almost a one-to-one correlation
going back decades
and if they're gonna get more negative
real rates gonna get more negative
in the months and years to come then
gold prices are just gonna keep going up
even just simply by that metric i mean
buffett's got to understand that
uh and he's got to understand that these
negative real rates are coming and so
therefore
certainly see why he'd want to start
getting in the sector okay let's talk
about scotia bank because you cover the
sector quite thoroughly
you know they've been fined 127 million
on top of the 800 million they already
paid for manipulating precious metals
markets
who scotia bank what does the story tell
you craig yeah max i mean scotiabank's
one of the largest bullion banks
and to see them now not only being fined
but
actually moving out of the business is
part of a trend you know that i think
you're seeing
the profitability of being a bullying
bank is falling off and now you've got
your compliance department breathing
down your neck as well
you know what are you doing here you
know and you're costing us money and
you're hurting our reputation
so the big news is that this is driving
scotia out of the business it may drive
more bullion banks out of the business
and hey max
we may finally get that sea change you
and i have been hoping for for the last
decade
finally get this pricing system to
change so it's good news to see
scotiabank
uh getting slapped like that all right
craig hemke ftf metals report thanks for
being on the kaiser report
hey thanks max always a pleasure and
that's going to do it for this edition
of the kaiser report with me
max keiser stacey herbert like to thank
our guest craig hemke
of tf metals report if you want to catch
us on twitter it's kaiser report until
next time
bye y'all
[Music]
you